over the past couple of weeks i posted a
couple of videos discussing the
whereabouts of popular piracy website
founders including mega upload kick ass
orange bittorrent and of course the
pirate bay in each and every one of
these videos i noticed a few common sets
of comments first you have the nostalgia
filled comments i was like part b
oh yeah the nostalgia dude you gave me
real nostalgia when you mentioned the
iso hunt that used to be the bomb when
the pirate bay was taken down and then
there were the comments that claimed
that these founders are heroes these
guys are legends they provided access to
information that was not available to
people who couldn't afford it in the
world without copyrights we could have
been heroes of the pirate bay creators
after that you have the comments that
are like i used to pirate because i was
either a kid or broke or both but now
that i can afford it i support content
creators and finally you have the ones
that have no remorse and outrightly
support piracy and to think that the
entire concept of copyright is wrong
just a friendly reminder it's always
morally accurate to use pirated adobe
love how piracy is referred to as
immoral yet more than 80 of companies
and services wouldn't know morality if
it hit them in the face double standard
clearly people seem to be quite
passionate and divided on this topic
either they pirate due to circumstance
or they pirate because they couldn't
care less if some big corporation makes
less money so is piracy morally wrong or
just merely illegal
starting with one of the most popular
arguments in support of piracy we have
the broke argument someone doesn't have
any money so they feel that if they want
to enjoy a piece of content or a game
they have departed it now there is some
argument to be made that a lot of
content is inaccessible to people from
developing countries for example a 60
game costs 1200 pesos or 4 500 rupees
while these are technically equivalent
amounts the cost of living and average
income of these countries are radically
different the average american household
pulls in 67 000 per year while the
average indian household only pulls in
204 000 rupees or about 2700 per year
considering this there's no doubt that
the average person living in a
developing country simply cannot afford
a lot of western content whether that be
games movies or music
but does this make piracy moral in these
situations
well the basis of this argument is that
affordability is what determines
morality but that doesn't really make
sense there are plenty of things that
most people can't afford for example i
genuinely cannot afford a g wagon but i
really want one would it be okay for me
to steal g wagon
i don't have any bad intentions i hope
mercedes does great and continues to
make phenomenal cars i simply can't
afford it and that's why i steal it
clearly there's no doubt that stealing
the car would be morally wrong so
morality is not based on affordability
hearing this a lot of pirates would
argue that by stealing the car i'm
directly costing mercedes money but by
pirating content they're not costing
adobe or microsoft any money if anything
they're simply losing potential revenue
and many pirates argue that if they
couldn't pirate it they wouldn't have
paid for the content anyway so there's
no loss in revenue either in other words
they're arguing that morality is
dependent on whether there's financial
consequences first of all i think
there's a fundamental flaw with this
argument if you truly weren't interested
in a piece of content you wouldn't have
gone through the hassle of pirating
usually when people make this argument i
think what they're trying to say is that
they wouldn't have paid full price for
the content because they don't think
it's worth that much but if you think
it's worth something there is some sort
of lost revenue also is it even up to
you to decide whether a piece of content
deserves money or not the basis of this
argument is essentially that the
morality of piracy depends on the
quality of the content if a piece of
content is worth the money it's not okay
to pirate but if a piece of content is
garbage pirate all you want but this
doesn't really make sense either let's
say you go to a theater to watch a movie
and it was absolute trash you wouldn't
watch that movie even if you got it for
free
in this case is it moral to ask for a
refund the theater didn't spend any
extra money to show the film to you
specifically even if you didn't go the
film would have played and there would
have likely been a lot of empty seats so
by asking for a refund you're not
costing the theater any money they're
just losing potential revenue but what
if everyone else who watched the movie
hated it just as much as you
is it moral if you get a refund and all
of them didn't clearly that would be
unfair either everyone should get a
refund or no one should so morality
doesn't depend on affordability
financial consequences or the quality of
the content in other words if you're
pirating a piece of content because you
either can't or don't want to pay for it
i'd argue that it's probably immoral but
there are cases in which it's not so
simple
one of the most understandable arguments
within the piracy scene is pirating for
professional development maybe you're a
freelance architect or a photo editor in
such cases you could use free software
but nothing quite compares to autodesk
inventor or adobe photoshop and when
everyone else they're competing against
is using this software it's extremely
difficult for you to produce a similar
quality of content using free software
so by pirating professional software
you're simply evening out the playing
field right you're not trying to
freeload or get something that you don't
need you're just trying to get the tools
that are required to progress in your
career and provide for your family and
whatever else while these are definitely
virtuous goals there is an argument that
could be made against this here's the
thing professional software is
specifically designed to give
professionals a competitive advantage
against the competition so is it fair
for you to reap those in benefits
without paying are they idiots for
paying or are you just a genius for
getting it for free
in my opinion the answer isn't clear cut
in this scenario because there is some
morality to both sides of the argument
and what about more basic pieces of
content what if instead of trying to
pirate premiere pro and excel a high
school student from a developing country
was trying to pirate a physics or
chemistry textbook just so they could
get through the class
these guys are just trying to get basic
education to improve their chances in
the real world also it's not like these
guys have a choice if you're simply
partying a movie for enjoyment you're
doing it out of free will and there
aren't any consequences for not pirating
a movie worst case scenario you'll be
bored for a few hours but if you don't
pirate a textbook that you can't afford
you may end up filling the class and
pushing back graduation or worse you may
end up dropping out so if you're
pirating for education or professional
use cases the morality is still
sometimes dicey but i'd argue that its
magnitude is more acceptable than
pirating for entertainment
so far we've mostly been trashing on
piracy but it's not always so bad
there's actually a handful of cases
where i think piracy is completely
acceptable for example what if a piece
of content is region blocked season five
of better call saul came out two years
ago in february of 2020. yet on netflix
you can only watch the first four
seasons this isn't to say that season 5
hasn't been launched on netflix as many
european countries were able to watch
season 5 on netflix as soon as it aired
on tv but american netflix viewers are
still waiting it's not like these
viewers are trying to freeload they're
willing to pay for it in fact they are
paying for it given that they have a
netflix subscription at least in this
scenario americans have another way of
watching this content if they have cable
tv but in many cases a piece of content
is just straight up banned in a region
and there are no legal ways to pay for
it and watch it in such a scenario i
don't think it's morally wrong to pirate
the region blocked content another case
in which piracy is acceptable is dead
online games at some point almost every
online game will be shut down due to a
dwindling player base take minecraft for
example right now it's not in any risk
of being shut down but what if it was
shut down 10 years from now would it be
morally wrong for current players of the
game to pirate a cracked version of the
game that runs off of third-party
servers in this scenario not only did
you pay for the game originally but the
game developer themselves shut down the
game because it was no longer profitable
or lucrative enough so if you pirate at
that game you're not really stealing
from the game developer given that they
aren't even selling the game anymore
also it's not like you're unwilling to
pay but rather that there is no way to
pay so i think we'd agreed that there's
nothing morally wrong about pirating
dead games but there is one more thing
to consider that makes the entire
discussion a lot more complex
up until this point all of our arguments
have been rooted in the perspective of
consumers whether that be students
professionals or just everyday people
but what about the perspective of
companies as that truly plays an
important role in all this as well for
example let's go back to the g-wagen
example what if mercedes did a giveaway
of a g-wagon if i win the giveaway then
i didn't steal the car but i still got
it for free and there's nothing morally
wrong with the situation given that
mercedes is consenting to give away the
car probably for marketing purposes
now it's not like companies want you to
pirate but there are significantly
different levels of toleration the movie
industry for example has no toleration
because they have little to benefit from
piracy if you get a movie for free it's
extremely unlikely that you'll also pay
for it later on but with something like
photoshop or powerpoint you may use it
for free for two three four years but if
you start making good money through your
career there's a strong likelihood that
you become a 10 20 30 year long customer
and for these companies letting users
part for a few years is often a great
investment in fact some companies would
rather you part their software for life
as opposed to using software from the
competition just listen to what bill
gates thinks about piracy although about
three million computers get sold every
year in
in china people don't pay for the
software
they will though
it's sort of a as long as they're going
to steal it we want them to steal ours
i sort of sort of get addicted and then
we somehow figure out how to how to
collect sometime in the next uh
in the next decade so you know it's a
great great place to be involved in and
it was a lot of fun which was i guess
the the key goal bill was laughing as he
said that but i think he was also being
dead serious one of the keys to
microsoft's dominance within the
operating system industry is that most
people would rather part windows and use
linux and that wouldn't be possible if
microsoft didn't make windows reasonably
easy to pirate with that in mind it
would be less morally wrong to pirate
windows than to part end game speaking
of the company side many pirates feel
that the morality of pirating also
depends on the status of the company if
a company is super big and or corrupt
it's okay to part from them but it's not
okay to pirate from a small game or
software developers while i would argue
that it's morally wrong to pirate from
either of them it would definitely be
more morally wrong to pirate from the
small developer as your individual
actions have a much greater impact on
them
at the end of the day there is no
clear-cut answer regarding the morality
of piracy in terms of a general rule of
thumb dawa i think the answer to
morality comes down to the purpose of
piracy if you're pirating purely for
entertainment it's almost always morally
wrong if you're pirating for education
or career development it's morally
ambiguous and depends on the specific
situation and finally if you're willing
to pay but can't get the content legally
then i think it's morally acceptable to
pirate the company's stance on piracy
along with their own actions also factor
into this but i think the purpose-based
determination is a pretty good rule to
go by but that's just what i think where
do you guys stand on the spectrum
comment that down below also drop a like
if you've ever pirated in the past and
of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one